- Am I supposed to stick
my dick in there or what?
I don't...
(intro music)
- Today we are guessing women's items.
- Tampons, maxi pads.
- Ned has a wife, I have met women.
- Yeah, we're gonna win.
- We are going to use our deep, deep
knowledge of lady stuff.
- Stop talking about how deep it is.
- Bring on, bring on the ladies' products.
(jazz music)
- What the heck, it's a Vader helmet.
- Is this like a cupcake
tray 'cause that's sexist.
- This is a hair dryer.
(dinging sound)
- Right, am I lying?
- How?
- Am I lying?
- Is this like, can men figure
out how to open a container?
- It's a hair dryer.
(dinging noise)
(buzzing sounds)
- Oh, oh okay.
- Oh, I was right, son!
- Ah, damn.
- I was right, son!
- We already knew what this was, boom.
One for one.
- I got two guesses, this
is either for your hair
or vaginal steamer.
(jazz music)
- Is it a cat toy?
- This is a fish hook.
- Oh yeah!
- This is like, the grappling hook
and then you climb up the
- Here you go, Robin.
Holy applesauce!
- Oh, yeah if you go
if your IUD gets stuck
you throw in the grappling
hook and (sound effect)
- Oh it's an IUD.
(dinging noise)
- This is an IUD?
- It is an IUD!?
- Holy IUD!
- This is the thing that goes
- It goes right here. Here?
- It either goes here or goes up in ya.
- But I know it stops the babies, right?
(dinging noises)
- Two for two.
(jazz music)
- Rehabing my shoulder muscles.
- This is how my grandma works out.
- This is to take the oil
off your freaking forehead.
Am I right, huh?
- Oh, that's not what I thought.
- Is this a dental dam?
(dinging noise)
- Yeah, I think it is.
- To eat out with this?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's for when you go down on someone but
don't want to get an STD.
(dinging noise)
(mumbling)
- We should use this.
- What if we had no clue
how to use it, you just.
- Like you light candles and you just like
whip it out.
- You ready?
- Wow, this is weird to lick it.
(jazz music)
- Tastes like floss.
- It tastes like what
a condom tastes like.
- It doesn't taste bad.
- I feel like licking this isn't fun.
- Tell the Try Guys to lick
the other mother fucker
on the face like this and they'll do it.
(jazz music)
(record scratch)
- I feel like I shouldn't
have witnessed that.
(jazz music)
- I feel like I'm being
tricked with this one.
(cricket noises)
- Pen and paper?
- Oh goodness!
- What, what, what?
- It's BIC for her.
- Oh my god.
- Fuck you.
- The gel grip does make
my ovaries feel good.
(jazz music)
- So we obviously won.
- I thought that I knew
things but I guess I don't.
- I was a solid B average.
- Boom, boom, boom.
- I learned this from
like watching my mom.
- Women are heroes.
- God damn heroes.
- I don't think I could get a
blow job with a dental damn.
- I don't know if the jokes
are crossing a line or not.
We'll have to check it out later.
(jazz music)
(outro sound effect)